豚どんどんドンキー呑気呆デー
ような彼はヤン9続々バクバクうーん
ヤンキーだードンとアーツ主の実はヤンキーに怒られるこんにちははじめシャツは尾根
再定義で今夜中の3時なんですけども
中野北の楽しみです買い物に行ってこようと思いますがただの買い戻しても面白くない
と思ったのでちょっとか
あった方法でお買い物しようかなと思っておりますその方法は論議法廷
目隠し買い物
やってみた僕が今から後輩を連れてドンキホーテに買い物に行きますそのドンキホーテ
で買い物をするときに僕は目隠しをして最後もします
もちろん危ないので後輩を1人つかせて一緒に行くんですけども広範囲なサポートいう
僕はもう女学生存知は北陸もあると動きってねものがめちゃくちゃ多い
すごいかとのものがあるんで本当にわけわかんなくねことがたくさんあるのでボケつの
理由
の考えがたくさんの量なるぼどの中で何よ女学習して選ぶのか
ドンキの中で難なく2 pot 官としたら何が手に入るのかというのをずっとずっと
栄杓なったので後輩が僕をちょっと誘導してくれつつ目隠しでどんげて買い物していき
ます果たして何が手に入るのが楽しみですねや袖ドンキに行ってみましょう
買うよ
me
when do you do
雑魚ガードできたよん
んえっ
ブーブー do
意外なって何時が思っちゃうってもう撮って罵倒
まあこうまずよ不幸ますよねっ
パッパッで大キタコレキタコレ
bouvet ジャーキンコーナーっ
そんな西川観音私これにせよこれ大丈夫
こんな好きだけって言うのっ
ブーブーってもうだーで a
何だろうですこれか
ブーバーこれはやばいブーバーまあいますか
いっ
まだ僕は何を買ったかと言うのはまだわかっていませんで今立と後輩が運んでもらうん
ですけども開いてねちょっと均なぜて置いて行ってもらいますよしかも分
ています
まぁまぁまぁまぁまぁまぁ回せないかこれは俺全然実用的だと思うのでこれはもう春
です
アリエルですふうにあっ
失礼じゃ
で彼ハープと言われてい saver
ありませんアン普通に作れるじゃん付けれ2室やリスクだったから by 月にも全然
歩い
2月
コレなにこれスモークガラスにするです名塩
車ですはっはっはスモークでございますちょっと使えないですねこれは次
まあこれはねーはっはっちゃったらなんだのまず何度の頃家でもない措置だと思います
amaran
パロていいんだったらねついで39グラムのプロテインですかこれこんな買う予定では
なかった私もちょっとケンリックせっかくなですけどと思いますズーマーっ
これはねーなんか座れ欲しかったこれでも世界一じゃねえスタジャン参加しますじゃ
ないんじゃー間カーってどんな
バッハ
プログラムを食べません
止めディフェンダーに俺は増えちゃったらを全然アリだろラブライブ3町のパズルです
時間ないんでますちまうときにこれやりますすぎ
あっ
これは何だろうな
えっにマックイーンですねさにマックイーンとこれは2人のパンツがなぜバスクじゃん
すごい皆さん2位バックルはずですちょっと統一てください
あっはい
はんっ
これはまあまあ女なかったのか
マジかじゃあ健全な蛇様これマジかーまたこんなの買う気を付けじゃなかっ積んだけど
が呪文じゃんこれあ次元入れましたいい奴じゃんフランスのプラズマクラスターぬーん
じぇ最後
プラズマクラスター空気清浄機のなんかすごいいいやつでした
ドンキでものを目隠しで買うと大体こんなものなんでこんなはなら集まる感じでござい
ますみなさん論議でモノを買う月はしっかり日分の確かめてから買いましょうかな
me おおおおおおおおおおおおおん